olá boa tarde a todos
falar no meia hugo e os o biólogo
eu queria saber que da platéia se alguém
ter noção exata do trabalho do biólogo
será que não sei realmente sabe o que a
gente faz porque eu acho que vocês têm
uma visão um pouco distorcida no nosso
trabalho né porque se você está doente
você procura um médico
se você é processado nos procure um
advogado se você grávida secretário
procurou um médico é o advogado né
mas o pior é que ele faz eu acho que
você imagina que a gente anda pela mata
contemplando cachoeira né vendo
borboletinha abrançando árvore todo
mundo pelado né
o que me tira gente eu faço isso vestido
sempre né sempre vestido mas a questão
que trabalha muito sério
hoje biólogo está na agropecuária para a
indústria está na genética está na
oncologia e também está no meio da mata
descobrindo espécies novas e
principalmente fazendo análises
ecológicos complexos para medir o
impacto das besteiras que a gente anda
fazendo pelo mundo certo mas a questão é
como é que surge um biólogo como que ele
nasce então vou contar um pouco da minha
história pra dar um exemplo tá como esse
aqui sou eu quando eu colher porque
ninguém está e como todo bom biólogos
todo lado de uma plantação de mar
macaxeira viu gente pelo amor de deus né
ela tá vendo como é o preconceito em
relação à nossa profissão tem que mudar
isso aí né
com certeza a plantação de macaxeira de
mandioca né
e quando eu era criança gostava de
revirar a terra se passava um bichinho
queria saber o que era perguntava para o
meu pai
ou seja eu era uma criança absolutamente
igual a vocês quando eram crianças
a criança a gente nasce biólogo ela
nasce curiosa o problema é que isso vai
sendo cortado da nossa infância e de
várias fases da nossa vida também quer
ver passa um sapo natal sabe o que a
criança quer fazer pega
eis que chega
voz delicada ao fundo falando a verdade
é a de saber marejada olhos isso vai
ficar cego na verdade acabou mesmo
nasceu ali uma criança traumatizada com
o sapo né
mas ele insiste ele insiste ainda vai
ficando mais velho
aí o tio dele chega assim biólogo vai
morrer pobre vai morrer pobre faz não
mais seguir outra profissão né bom
felizmente isso não aconteceu comigo
tive paz que me apoiaram e eu resolvi
tentar e hoje gente o que eu posso dizer
é que eu sou completamente apaixonado
pelo que eu faço eu acordo todos os dias
apaixonado pelo que faço pelos lugares
que visitei para as pessoas que conheci
pelos animais que fotografei a questão
aqui também
eu vivo disso é através da biologia que
eu pago as minhas contas eo melhor de
tudo que eu nem preciso tirar férias
porque já trabalha durante as férias
isso com certeza fez com que as pessoas
de certa forma se identificassem com
trabalho e principalmente através do meu
trabalho no facebook que o trabalho
também com fotografia
eu postar uma foto e as pessoas davam
lic
puxa que legal só que comecei a perceber
que as pessoas curtindo a capa do meu
trabalho
o que eu quero dizer quando eu coloco
uma foto de um animal no facebook um
texto o que as pessoas estão vendo é só
aquele animal e elas gostam dele um like
a questão gente que o biólogo ele é um
cientista por trás de tudo aquilo a
pesquisas muito complexas e ciência
gente é o fator de evolução de uma
sociedade
nenhuma nação evoluiu ciência é muito
importante então olha as pessoas gostam
do que o posto e ciência tão importante
por que não utilizar esse meio para
levar a ciência para a sociedade
e é exatamente isso que vim falar aqui
no santos no texas como levar a ciência
para a sociedade
ok então eu vou fazer vou colocar
algumas fotos que tirei né ao longo do
meu trabalho e vou mostrar pra vocês o
que está por trás dessas fotos então vou
começar pelo lado logo da onça pintada
uma me ferir
é o predador das américas animal
ameaçado de extinção o felino é todo
mundo gosta da onça não é isso
a questão é traiu consegui tirar essa
foto lá no pantanal
foi preciso que primeiro tivesse 11
neste hoje no brasil para ter o onça é
preciso que esse lugar esteja preservado
na verdade o problema é que esse pra
isso né pra você preservar
não basta só ativismo e fiscalização não
gente você precisa de ciência por trás
disso é preciso saber que ela come de
que forma ela utiliza aquele ambiente e
principalmente como ligar populações que
estão isoladas para manter aquela
espécie né
viveu durante mais tempo agora para isso
acontecer eu preciso de pessoas como o
pessoal do da ong pantera do instituto
pró carnívoros do instituto onça-pintada
que trabalham para a conservação desta
espécie no pantanal
pra que você inclusive possa ir lá no
pantanal agora contratar um guia local
ele vai te levar na beira do rio você
pode tirar uma fotografia que nem é essa
ou seja é a ciência atuando na
conservação atuando na economia porque
você vai injetar dinheiro na economia
local
ok agora é muito muito muito fácil falar
de uns porque o que todo mundo conhece
ok agora quem é que conhece o cachorro
vinagre
alguém já ouviu falar em cachorro
vinagre é um mamífero lindo maravilhoso
como vocês estão vendo e é uma espécie
brasileira e na amazônia que é o lugar
onde mais tem ele é uma lenda
imagina no resto do país agora quem
conhece tigre e leão elefante
rinoceronte
todo mundo conhece né nenhum desses
animais são brasileiros
o que você conhece todos esses animais
ameaçados de extinção da áfrica e da
ásia
ele conhece o cachorro vinagre animal
nós a resposta é muito simples nós não
temos uma educação voltada para a
valorização da fauna nacional e isso
gente é muito grave
sabe por quê porque através dessa
valorização eu consigo fazer com que
vocês conheçam e que lutem
a preservação e através disso consigo
patrocinador existe patrocinador
brasileiro colocando dinheiro lá na
conservação do panda mas que não conhece
o cachorro vinagre entender qual o
problema
beleza mas se eu me esforçar bastante
eu consigo puxar financiamento pra
cachorro vinagre sabe por quê
porque ele a mãe e filho cut bonitinho
agora imagina só falar de conservação do
animal que não é assim tão querido netão
nesse site e vocês estão vendo o animal
que mais mata ser humano no planeta que
é o mosquito
eu fui quase vítima inclusive eu peguei
duas mamárias ao mesmo tempo é sério e
um caso bem raro diga se de passagem e
eu tive 21 dias no hospital oito dias na
uti
quase morri fui salvo é a nas últimas
graças a uma experiente equipe médica ea
minha e sogra ea sogra fez uma promessa
que se sobrevivesse à malária ela iria
andando de fortaleza canindeense 1 150
quilômetros comigo juntos acredito eu
queria né aproveitar esse cadex para
agradecer à equipe médica ea minha e só
grafia sônia falar que vou pagar
promessa de moto talvez né
mas enfim o que importa aqui do lado do
mundo que vocês estão vendo uma jararaca
que realmente uma espécie de pessoas
sempre têm o potencial de morte e o povo
é o seguinte é peçonhenta mata hamas
tenha jibóia que não é peçonhenta mata
também a manter esse bicho cobre que ele
não faz nada mata esse negócio parece
com cobra mata também na verdade o
problema já que quando você faz isso
além de causar um desequilíbrio em toda
a cadeia alimentar você também atrapalha
potenciais farmacológicos
só para vocês terem uma idéia através do
veneno desse bichinho e você consegue
sintetizar o captopril quem tem pressão
alta ou parente com pressão alta sabe do
que estou falando
não é um remédio para pressão alta
através do veneno da cascavel você
consegue sintetizar um anestésico mais
poderoso que a morfina então
entendendo o qual é o impacto de você
matar muitos animais é muito mais do que
simplesmente aquele bichinho que morreu
você está prejudicando toda uma
conservação inclusive a medicina agora é
ciência falando de conservação para a
qual a medicina certo
falando de caça de abate de animais
silvestres
foi exatamente isso que eu quis fazer na
minha vida acadêmica terminando o
doutorado falta um mês inclusive e eu tô
é o meu a minha tese sobre a caça no
brasil
eu rodei todos os biomas do brasil para
saber qual era a região mais impactadas
pela casa
e advinha qual é o nordeste a caatinga
aqui certo e um animal símbolo da
caatinga e da casa do nordeste é arriba
sam que aqui chamada de abuan ti né
quem não lembra que no ceará um pouco
tempo atrás você andava pelas estradas e
viam as pessoas segurando cordas com
dezenas de avante pedradas né
isso diminuiu diminuiu mas a cas ainda
continua bastante presente aqui certo
como é que eu faço pra mudar isso já que
é um problema e é cultural vem de
criança né toda criança tem uma
baladeira
o interior na verdade e menina com um
baladeiro um estilingue é pra quem não
sabe menino com bala de estilingue é o
seguinte pouse um passarinho atira
após um café passou calando atira atira
passou atirando a tia também né
é um perigo então como eu posso mudar
isso tem que mudar nessa criançada então
por que por exemplo eu posso chegar numa
escola pública e unir a quem sabe falar
a criançada me traz todas as baleias mas
as baladeiras que vocês vêem que eu
coloque de volta pra vocês um binóculo
de baixo custo e isso é legal
elas param de caçá e passa observares
bacana observação de aves hoje gente é
uma economia que gera milhões no mundo
inteiro está crescendo muito no brasil
que pode estar formando futuros guias aí
por exemplo né
e esse é legal agora falando do ceará
vocês sabiam que no ano passado foi
descoberta uma nova espécie que não será
nunca
distantes na ciência descoberta aqui na
serra de baturité é um porco espinho
aqui chamado de quando ele chama quando
de baturité né
e aí você chega com algo bacana isso que
você falou
agora eu quero saber mais você falou que
a gente precisa saber mais como eu faço
isso é bom
poderia ser um canal de televisão né de
repente como que o biólogo descobre uma
espécie como que ele descobre o que
aquela espécie come mas infelizmente
você não vai achar isso no canal de lei
de televisão porque o que hoje os canais
de televisão somente possui os mais
perigosos os mais pessoas aos mais cut
mas nunca é uma coisa voltada para a
ciência né
então o que a gente resolveu fazer criar
um canal então em primeira mão que o
lance pra vocês
o canal usou o que a gente fez reuniu
uma equipe de biólogos malucos uma
equipe de produtores malucos de cinema
certo trabalhando com drone trabalhando
com equipamentos de filmagem de alta
tecnologia e vai ser disponível lá no
youtube tá pra vocês saberem como foi
campeão e descobriu-se espécie como foi
que como a gente sabe o que ela come
enfim e a partir de 2015 esse canal vai
ser lançado mas vocês podem se inscrever
agora e curtir esse título e que a gente
fez do condado de baturité
para saber tudo isso e eu espero que
vocês se inscrevam o mais rápido
possível e bonitinho né gente
lá é maravilhoso canal zorzett ó é um
canal que envolve humor na ciência
principalmente e natureza
ok então espero que todos vocês curva
agora tem mais coisa para ser feita com
certeza tem a gente precisa levar isso
até a mão das pessoas e que está na mão
das pessoas
o smartphone né então hoje você já tem
vários aplicativos que te ajudam isso um
exemplo por exemplo um exemplo é o urubu
bairro que é isso você está dentro do
seu carro você viu o animal atropelado
na estrada você desce tira foto do
animal e manda para web
o corpo de biólogos vai identificar e
vôos e junto com esses biólogos vão
fazer bom fazer parte da rede social da
maior rede social de conservação no
brasil hoje já são 450 milhões de
animais atropelados todos usam
hoje no brasil é mais que o dobro da
população brasileira morta todo ano um
absurdo
e aí você vai colaborar para que isso
diminua agora tem outras idéias também
ambiente por exemplo fazer um aplicativo
onde você chega na cidade e ele te dá as
trilhas mais próximos para você fazer
com os animais que estão presente nessas
trilhas por exemplo é uma idéia que está
desenvolvendo para os próximos anos a
gente espera que isso seja feito em
breve
agora a questão é que vocês sabem por
que que eu acho que isso tudo é
plenamente possível porque já deu certo
já deu certo hoje no brasil né alegre dá
certo no passado hoje não é engraçado é
eu vou passar aqui próximo slide eu
queria que vocês levantasse a mão quem
vai ser lembrado essa imagem por favor
isso já deu muito certo né gente
para quem tem menos de 20 anos é só o
chocolate surpresa
ele vinha com um card uma foto que era
de vários é é segmentos de astronomia
paleontologia mas durante cinco anos
onde teve uma série só sobre animais de
trás desse cargo você tinha informações
sobre aquele animal
você pode colecionar isso em alguns isso
influenciou tanta gente tanta gente
inclusive eu e isso morreu lembra do
mundo de beakman lembra do castelo
rá-tim-bum tíbia eo perônio né
hoje não tem não tem mais nada então por
que a gente não pode mudar esse quadro
né porque ao invés da galinha pintadinha
você não tenha 11 pintadinha que já é
pintada
você não precisa nem pintar a galinha
pelo amor dela
cuidado porque você não tenho quando
pintadinho o cachorro vinagrete lá vem o
cachorro é engraçado ia ser legal
uma coisa que valoriza a nossa fauna
gente não é esse
e eu queria demais demais mesmo que 2014
fosse o ano que a gente pudesse lançar
essa ideia mais longe porque porque em
eu acho que você se lembra dessa notícia
como as pessoas vão lembrar na frente do
instituto nacional de cardiologia no rio
de janeiro morreu um fotógrafo
ele morreu de infarto paradoxalmente na
frente do instituto de cardiologia
esse fotógrafo era nada mais nada menos
que luís cláudio marigô ele era o
fotógrafo dos animais do chocolate
surpresa e eu queria muito que esta data
serve pelo menos para que a gente
conseguisse levar a mensagem do luiz
cláudio ainda mais longe do que levou a
simplesmente divulgar natureza através
da arte de mão dada com a ciência porque
ciência gente é a melhor herança que
você pode dar a uma nação eu convido
todo mundo assinar esse testamento
comigo e meu muito obrigado